oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and you thought it was
gonna be a [ __ ] oh I'm day ain't that
about a [ __ ] you thought it was gonna
be one of those days nothing's gonna
happen
and hey I just popped up on your
[ __ ] ass just like that you
follow me we don't know nothing we just
do things when we do it that's it tell
everybody you don't know nothing about
nothing
Uncle Joe we here ready to fill up the
[ __ ] don't throats pilot to Bombardier
you bad [ __ ]
[Music]
become realities to me you [ __ ]
savages you got this [ __ ] that [ __ ]
boot smoked before he shot Lincoln and
I'm saying we got these [ __ ] blue
cookies from perennial always I'm always
you [ __ ] know how we do it and
for the edibles [ __ ] sunset herbal
still holding it the [ __ ] down 200
milligrams if these [ __ ] decals are
you kidding me or what you want to [ __ ]
around or you want a micro dose with
your little [ __ ] buddies and some
[ __ ] huka spot or whatever the [ __ ]
you're doing these days we're getting
down with no delay you understand me
with Denver bound then we'll get
prepared
[Music]
[Music]
would Denver bound and getting prepared
and Alabama will see you [ __ ]
next week
[Music]
oh [ __ ] would like the [ __ ] on
fire in here today and this ain't no
smoke machine this is the real deal this
is what you signed up for you want to
[ __ ] around with these okey-doke
[ __ ] telling you that cousins
with Cheech and Chong this is the last
of these [ __ ] people it is but in his
room with just walking into this room
you test [ __ ] positive we should do a
lot of [ __ ] things together my man
Sam triply tellingly they wanted to wage
the AIDS together next thing you know
Lee will be one of those gay bars with a
[ __ ] mask on with a hole with a
zipper asking himself what the [ __ ]
happened to my life I'm going back to
Emerson Emerson Emerson I'm going back
to Amazon zippered what what is it
what's going on Sammy trips in the
[ __ ] house we ain't [ __ ] around
here Denver bound me and Lisa Anna on a
flight that night we're popping edibles
we got least favorite reefer blew
cookies Deanne Colorado's waiting for us
with 22 pounds of shitty group and
Hitler's backyard I'm saying all those
old [ __ ] bones and [ __ ] makes the
best reefer anyway we're here would quit
the church always happening now so if
you're under 18 hang up now you little
perverted [ __ ] you little
[ __ ] we're here we're queer you
follow me we get the party started you
know I'm saying
I don't know nothing I don't know
nothing neither no nothing I don't want
to know nothing
[Music]
I'll eat it if you want just to prove to
this nothing that look at let's see say
by the way he's accusing me make an
accusation I'm a man of many accusations
but not a lot of conviction she's I'm
saying so get your [ __ ] together Jackson
put it like a [ __ ] lizard of death I
found movie couple years ago I finally
found the [ __ ] envelope that Sam gave
me for [ __ ] my birthday it was hidden
in the trunk of the car can you believe
that [ __ ] so I got pulled over I got 20
years but that's what happens when you
live in the big Wild West have a seat my
brother's side were you thinking about
watch the [ __ ] SAP Sunday night I
didn't finish and then there was one
left here over the weekend we had a nice
time The Comedy Store for my 55th
birthday I'm an old man but let me tell
you something that's over you know
what's on Denver tomorrow night and the
shows are sold out six I even added an
extra one there done good you filthy
[ __ ] animals that's why I love you
the next [ __ ] [ __ ] is Alabama sweet
home I'll be there the following week
with the [ __ ] Cuban cowboy had a big
dick and a bag of reefer you understand
me in fact the mule is on its way to
Alabama right now as we speak
he'll be hitting Birmingham by Saturday
by Tuesday will be in Huntsville tip-top
Magoo stars of debt will come a million
big Huntsville Atlanta I'm not coming to
this year so you better get on that
[ __ ] skateboard and get your [ __ ]
ass to [ __ ] now or where they going
punch Ville Huntsville that's right wait
talk is cheap
it's time for abundant you know I'm
saying everybody wants to [ __ ] go to
heaven but nobody wants to die let's do
this [ __ ]
Sammy trips in the [ __ ] house
oh [ __ ] I'm reading a good book the
corporation my TJ English out March
[ __ ] 20th has a nice little story in
there by [ __ ] Fidel's mistress and
how she was seen in New Orleans that
they of them they sent her back a week
before the [ __ ] Kennedy assassination
some good [ __ ] in there TJ English does
it again that's [ __ ] crazy dog it's
[ __ ] dog it's a [ __ ] up world out
there Marlon Brando blue Superman they
do testing in the article big dick in
Cuba the guy had the big dick and Cuban
Godfather too they hunted him down they
went in search of the big 16 inches cold
thick 16-inch cold cold waking up in the
morning even when it's [ __ ] like 10
below was like 14 inches he never got
dick pool or whatever pool dick anyway
what are we talking about here if you
ain't gonna bond yeah listen if you
ain't got reefers snort one of grandmas
chemo tablets I've done it not bad your
eye twitches for three days but who
gives a [ __ ] you ain't got nowhere to go
anyway
[Music]
[Music]
mom sama so I'm saying don't eat the
shrooms we'll time the time listen
everybody needs to do a shroom from time
to time believe it or not we're gonna do
a ton of them this weekend we don't know
what he's walking into I've been getting
emails they gonna take you on Friday
there's some catastrophic tune when they
put you in I just blow weed smoke on you
it's part of a gives a [ __ ] you dirty
you've got a college degree you're doing
everything right if you're doing
everything wrong when I tell you nothing
oh you're doing everything right the
worst thing that happens you'll fall off
a mountain and get stitches here we go I
feel I'm happy I feel so sad come on
over let's do it
this is a great song this is least B
this is least eat
she was my woman I love the soul but
it's too late now I've let her go
listen Felicity ready this is please
song ready everybody has already I'm
going through changes never simply going
through changes I'm going to change it
not with you oh you want to Colorado you
there's no oxygen I gotta take your
trade now there's no oxygen how you
gonna trade on the little bar that's
what I've been trying to train you on
the big bar cuz you're gonna pass out
tomorrow I know they're gonna come get
me at one point Joey
you passed down my man two hundred
milligrams here is completely different
over there and we're going deep we ting
like a thousand we're just going right
off the bat you can sleep when you leave
the window
it's 39 degrees you leave your window
open a little bit just a little bit get
those bundles and you'll [ __ ] cover
the curtains you don't know when you'll
wake up you have no idea the airs
thinner you sleep like a [ __ ] baby
you get up a bowl of green chilly back
to the crib back to the crib you're I'm
sayin
ain't no sightseeing I don't wanna know
on the run you want to sightsee go see
the whales by yourself are you ready for
the big meal let's do this [ __ ] let's
get that long in tip-top condition you
can run into a [ __ ] Amazon or [ __ ]
[Music]
um job the exercise through changing it
is tremendous [ __ ] Jam I think it's
off a valium for don't quote me you know
me dog we've been smoking whatever I
started early this morning I was coming
out all those [ __ ] Joe Weider pills
last night
Joe Weider you know [ __ ] GNC whatever
they have these [ __ ] gamma gamma or
melatonin and some other [ __ ] routes
you snore them with [ __ ] New Moon
forget about it and you're in [ __ ]
heaven let's do this ready done let's
get down with no delay oh [ __ ] I'm the
king of rock let's go
take it to the limit there you go push
that [ __ ] there you go
[ __ ] my boom there you go there you go
they all always all it would take skate
like me it's on the way ready it's there
already made the [ __ ] call for he
likes blue cookie so I got a blue
cookies anyway I love you [ __ ]
look at Sammy trips looking good looking
good
I'm saying he's a good boy now he's a
good boy now everybody gotta be a good
boy now alright no more [ __ ] nothing
if you're off the maracas pills were all
in we're going deep it's all over but
the shouting what the [ __ ] do you want
from me what am i a [ __ ] fortune
teller I know nothing nothing all I know
is that a smoked reefer and crack
[ __ ] jokes with my favorite family
the Church of what's happening now Oh
book it I won't lie bingo and so all of
us in it pull up in yelling so I wanna
pony normal book at Le Royal Horse
Antonio sabato Mallya illegal a
Santissima Katya a goalie your bottle ha
ha there you go that's your Cuban mini
for the day use it every day we all
learn something when you crap the fart
oh [ __ ] it's our team
it's our Dean this is Lou this is Lily
in the middle of the night as my friend
moves right there who the [ __ ] you can
get dealing with young Sam Jesus Christ
[Music]
alright youtube.com slash C's last Joey
Diaz is the place to be
we're getting ready to launch this
[ __ ] monster here oh [ __ ] I love you
oh [ __ ] here we go
[Music]
was starting this [ __ ] party early
we're gonna be listening
by the time we land in Denver it's all
over we'll take all over
[Music]
showed me around what we doing your life
that was so [ __ ] faster than anyway
did you think about that leash uncle
Joey would we're doing something we're
talking we'll [ __ ] ha ha ha something
you know I don't know that about Bob I
don't know what's going on I don't give
a [ __ ] every time I watch a TV I got
upset so that ever since Diane so I got
off the [ __ ] news the world's got
this [ __ ] ever since Diane Sawyer got
all [ __ ] world news tonight the world
country [ __ ] I love you notice that I
want Diane Sawyer back
I wanna now you understand me bring me
that head of Diane Sawyer let's start a
whole new channel at 7 o'clock the
church or what's happening now with
Diane Sawyer dropping knowledge smoking
weeds forget about it that's my [ __ ]
favorite ever since she got off ABC's
you know that [ __ ] knew it ship is
gonna get fat youtube.com slash c / joey
dis either in a yob [ __ ]
I'm with you you're with me and they
wanna be with us without you [ __ ]
I have nothing so let's do this one for
the road you follow me what the [ __ ] you
lookin at me like I like I robbed your
purse a long time ago
[Music]
all right God suckers
you guys think we're [ __ ] around here
running the charity I'm sacrificing
lungs for you people you understand me
who does that feet who who talks up and
nobody anyway I love your [ __ ]
youtube.com / c / joey d response
podcast it's sponsored by Squarespace
you need a website go to Squarespace and
tell them uncle Joey sent you and what's
the other oh [ __ ] listen if you coming
to the shows and ever shave your [ __ ]
so you gotta use Harry's razors go to
Harry's and press it I don't even know
you need to press it press in church I'm
gonna get your free [ __ ] get whatever
the [ __ ] it is you like these huh leave
me I was like Rudolph Valentino before
the operation would anyway I love you
[ __ ] that's a soul top but Sweet
Home Alabama Huntsville stand up live
next [ __ ] Thursday Friday Saturday
and then New York I'm gonna come back
through the back door if I was in the
witness relocation plan where do you
land Newark or Nyack now yeah that's
where I'm landing one show March 21st
8:00 p.m. one of my favorite [ __ ]
clubs in the country they got good pizza
they got Chinese food up there in Nyack
and they got something else was good
anyway it don't matter
world--well counting points here
[ __ ] though I'm looking sharp this
[ __ ] look what the [ __ ] Johnny was am
bony head to 118 and 3rd Avenue you
understand me
a shout-out to my little brother in
Secaucus mending the wing Timmy how're
you can't drive with a hook [ __ ]
anyway stay black Denver wash your
[ __ ] shave that [ __ ]
we'll come into town beep the flying
Jews flying [ __ ] in tonight we're
going
don't worry about what we're doing just
worry about what you ain't gotta [ __ ]
do it you follow me
stay black I love you youtube.com / c /
Joey Diaz my little brother Sammy trip
I'll let you bowl I hate your deals look
look at Johnny's I'm beak and your
favorite [ __ ] up on the world uncle
Joey Boogaloo
where's the envelope vs alright you know
I love your [ __ ] Roy boy until
I be like the horny stay black
[Music]